Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Suleyman Cengiz
Problemi görüyorsunuz.
Milyonlarca türüz bu topraklarda,
bu sularda yaşayan.
Ama bunlardan sadece bir tanesi
ortaya çıkıyor ve diyor ki
"Ben hepinizden daha güçlüyüm,
daha akıllıyım.
Ben ne dersem o olur!"
Ve sonunda bütün egemenliği eline alıyor,
sorunlar yaratıyor,
çözmeye çalışıyor vesaire.
Sorun yaratırken, onları çözerken
daha büyük sorunlara yol açıyor
ve sonunda bir gün bakıyorsunuz ki
"Ben gidiyorum." diyor.
"Mars'a gidiyorum."
Niye? Ne oldu?
"Burada artık yaşanmıyor." diyor.
Bugün konuşacağımız konu bu.
Çıkış yolu peki bu durumda nedir?
Konuşmamı kolaylaştırmak için
bir benzetmeyle başlayacağım.
Bir kavramla başlayacağım.
Bu kavram "sorun kimyası".
Şimdi lütfen etrafınıza bir bakın.
Bu sahnede, oturduğunuz yerde,
hatta cebinizde olanlar...
Hepsini saydığınız zaman,
sayabilirseniz,
ne kadar farklı madde var burada?
Herhâlde on binleri bulur.
Ankara'da ne kadar var?
Belki milyonlarca.
Dünyada dediğiniz zaman
belki trilyonlarca hayırlı şeyler var.
Şu tuttuğum kumanda cihazının içinde bile
500 tane ayrı parça var.
Ama madde kimyası bizim bildiğimiz,
lisede okuduğumuz
madde kimyası diyor ki
bütün bunlar trilyonlarca olabilir.
Ama bunların hepsi 119 tane
temel elementten yapılmıştır.
Hatta daha ileri gidelim.
İnsan vücudu dediğimiz
bu son derece karmaşık şey
yaklaşık galiba 65-70 civarında
elementten oluşuyor.
Onların çoğu da karbon,
hidrojen ve oksijen.
Sorun kimyası,
bu benzetmeden ortaya çıkıyor.
Madem ki 119 tane element birleşiyorlar,
trilyonlarca ayrı maddeye
dönüşüyorlar -bileşiklere-
ve bu bileşiklerin hiçbirinin
bir diğerine benzer tarafı da yok.
Renkleri, kokuları, işlevleri farklı.
Peki, ben buradan acaba
başka bir yerde yararlanabilir miyim?
Sorunlarımızı da oturup alt alta yazsak,
şu salonda bir anket yapsak,
herkes on tane önemli
sorununu yazsın desek,
herhâlde binlerce sorun çıkar.
İçinde bazı ortaklıklar da vardır,
ama toplam olarak herhâlde
1-2 bin tane özgün sorun çıkar.
Şimdi soru şu,
-aynı madde kimyasına benzeterek-
acaba
bu sorunlar da madde
kimyasında olduğu gibi
daha az elementten oluşmuş olabilir mi?
Bunu niye sorduğumu tahmin edersiniz.
Eğer böyle bir şey varsa
o zaman ben
o milyonlarca ayrı soruna
tek tek çözüm bulmak yerine,
belki o elementlere doğru yönelir
ve bu sorunları
o şekilde çözmeye çalışırım.
Bugün içinden çıkılamayıp
insanoğlunun buradan
kaçmak zorunda kaldığı sorunları
anlayabilmek için,
bir cins benzetici terim koyduk ortaya.
Sorun kimyası.
Sorun kimyası, gittikçe
daha karmaşık bileşikler üretiyor
ve ilginç de bir özelliği var;
madde kimyası yan yana duran iki madde,
durup dururken birleşmiyorlar.
Siz özel bir çaba gösterirseniz
laboratuvar ortamında veya gerçekte
bunlar birleşiyorlar.
Ama madde kimyasına benzemez
şekilde sorun kimyası böyle değil.
İki tane sorun,
kim tarafından oluşturulmuş olursa olsun,
suçlusu kim olursa olsun,
bir süre sonra birleşiyorlar
ve kendilerine benzemeyen
ve kendilerinden daha karmaşık,
daha zor çözülebilen yeni bir
veya birkaç sorun üretiyorlar.
Aynı kefir mayası gibi.
Evlerinizde kullandığınız kefir de
durduğu yerde bakteriler,
yeni bakteriler üretiyorlar.
İşte bu sorun kimyasının ürettiği
karmaşıklık böyle artıyor.
Her karmaşıklık önümüze servis ediliyor.
"İşte böyle bir çocuğunuz oldu,
buyrun şimdi bunu çözün." diye.
Bugün dünyanın
ve onun bir parçası olan Türkiye'nin
karşı karşıya bulunduğu olgu bu.
Bunun sonunda yine bir terim kullanıyoruz.
Bir sorun stoku oluşuyor.
Sorun stoku bir taraftan artıyor,
ama bir taraftan da insanlar
bir bölümünü çözüyorlar.
Eğer yeni üreyenlerle çözülenler
birbiriyle dengede ise
o toplumlar geri gitmiyorlar.
İleri de gitmiyorlar,
olduklar yeri muhafaza edebiliyorlar.
Eğer daha çok sorun çözebiliyorlar,
stoku ufaltabiliyorlarsa
o zaman -yani boşlarını ufaltıyorlarsa
bir ticaret terimi gibi-
o zaman giderek gelişiyorlar.
Gelişemeyen, geri giden,
yok olmaya doğru giden toplumlar ise
sorun stokunun altında ezilen toplumlar.
Türkiye'nin bunların neresine geldiği
filan konusu, hiç açıklamaya lüzum yok.
Sorun stokumuzun mutlaka
ve mutlaka azaltılması gerekiyor.
İki yönlü bir çaresizlik doğuyor:
Bir tanesi
bırakın çözmeyi,
bunlar birbirleriyle
etkileşerek büyüyorlar;
bırakın çözmeyi,
bunları anlamak dahi zor.
İkincisi de
milyonlarca milyarlarca insan var
ve tavşanlar gibi de
bir taraftan ürüyoruz.
İki yüzyılda,
iki yüz bin yılda üreyen
insan sayısı bir milyar iken,
son iki yüzyılda yedi milyar ürüyor.
2050 yılında 20 milyara
çıkacağı düşünülüyor
ve Türkiye, dünyanın da
bunu besleyemeyeceği öngörülüyor.
Bu kadar büyük nüfus da bir taraftan
bekleşip duruyor
ve bu sorunlara baktıkça
biraz haklı olarak düşünüyor ki
"Ben bunlar karşısında ne yapabilirim,
benim herhangi bir gücüm yok ki."
Çaresizliğin bir boyutu bu,
bir boyutu da ne olup
bittiğini anlamak konusu.
Şimdi buradan çıkan net bir şey var,
bu yeni birleşik çaresizliğe
karşı daha yetkin,
daha büyük bir akla ihtiyacımız var.
İyi güzel, ama onun karşısında
çok büyük bir engel var.
O engel de şu,
yaygın bir yanılgı var.
O yanılgı şöyle diyor,
"Efendim, biz sorunları biliyoruz.
Çözümlerini de biliyoruz,
hiç bu konuda boşuna konuşmayın.
Bizim elimizde güç yok.
Güç olsa biz bunları çözeriz."
Bu yaygın kalıp -şunu söyleyebilirim-
aradığınız yetkin aklın
önündeki en büyük engel.
Bireysel olarak da böyle,
kurumsal olarak da böyle,
toplumsal olarak da böyle,
küresel olarak da böyle.
Bunu böyle düşündüğümüz sürece,
biz bu yetkin aklı üretemeyeceğiz.
Allah'tan dünyada böyle
düşünmeyen insanlar da var,
onlar da bir taraftan
bu konularda çalışıyorlar.
Bu, Albert Einstein'ın söylediği
ifade edilir, ona izafe edilir.
"Bana dünyayı kurtarmak
için bir saat verselerdi,
bunun 55 dakikasını sorunu anlamak için,
son 5 dakikasını da ona
çözüm bulmak için harcardım."
Bu bence her evin, her kurumun,
her devlet dairesinin kapısına
yazılması gereken bir özdeyiş.
Şimdi peki bizim aklımızdan
bu kadar şikayet ettik.
Niye, ufak mı bizim aklımız?
Yetmiyor mu bu işlere?
Evet, aklımız belki büyük,
ama onu daraltan şeyler var.
Daraltıcılar var.
Bakın siz de, şimdi bir zihin haritası
göstereceğim size,
o zihin haritasından beğenin beğenin.
Ekran ufak olduğu için
anca o kadarını sığdırdık.
Yoksa gerçekte bundan çok daha fazla.
Bakın,
bulunduğunuz yerden
rahatça görüyorsunuz.
Dünyaya gelirken getirdiğimiz miras,
kalıtsal mirasımız,
ondan sonraki beslenmemiz,
hamilelik süresinde
annemizin ne yediği, ne içtiği,
hangi müziği dinlediği,
kimle kavga ettiği,
kim tarafından dövüldüğü vesaire.
Ondan sonra tutkularımız,
endişelerimiz, korkularımız,
inançlarımız,
nefretlerimiz,
tutkularımız, kinlerimiz...
Hepsi bir araya geliyor,
hepsi aklımızdan
bir ufak parçayı koparıyor.
Bunu biraz görselleştirebilmek için
şöyle bir şey yaptım.
Tabii herkesin akıl daraltıcıları farklı.
Aynı cinsler olabilir, ama onların
herkesteki karşılığı farklı.
Bazısında sıfır, bazısında çok.
Şimdi şunu varsayın ki
bir kişinin aklı bu kadar olsun.
Tam aklı, kısıtlanmamış,
daraltıcılarla kesilip
biçilmemiş aklı bu kadar.
Burada şimdi başlıyor şeyler,
işte kalıtım geliyor,
bir parçasını alıyor götürüyor.
Bir bölümü takıntılarınızdan gidiyor.
Bir bölümü inançlarınızdan,
belki yasaklıyorsunuz olayı.
Bir bölümü tutkularınız.
Bir bölümü işte mesleki deformasyonlar,
korkular vesaire derken
böyle bir alan kalıyor.
O demin kocaman
gösterdiğimiz pasta dilimi
bu kadar kaldı, sağından solundan
tırpanlandığı zaman bu kadar kaldı.
İşte bu, bir kişininki.
Buna bir numaralı kişi diyelim.
Bunun yanına ikinci, üçüncü,
dördüncü kişiler geldiği zaman
tabii ki onların da daraltıcıları var,
ama bununla aynı değil.
Bu bizim için çok büyük bir şans.
Çözüm varsa burada var.
Bakın bu, birinci kişinin daralmış aklı.
İkinci kişininki,
dikkat ediyorsanız ondan farklı
ve bunun dışına çıkan tarafı da var,
ortak olan tarafları da var.
Üçüncü kişi bu, dördüncü kişi bu.
Dört kişinin ortak olarak
ortaya koyabilecekleri kısım,
ortak akıl diye taradığım
o gri kısımda duruyor.
Peki bir de bunun farklılıkları var.
Burada bugün diğer
konuşmacılar da çok bahsettiler,
farklılıkların önemi konusunda.
O farklılıklar da
ayrı bir alan oluşturuyor
ve ikisi bir araya geliyor.
İşte birleşik akıl dediğimiz,
peşinde olduğumuz,
yetkin akıl dediğimiz şey işte bu akıl.
Bunun da dikkat ederseniz
çok sayıda insana ihtiyaç var,
ama akılları birbirinden farklı olan
insanlara ihtiyacımız var.
Bu farklılıklara bugün
burada çok değinildi.
Ben de bir kere daha
vurgulamak istiyorum,
çözüm de burada yatıyor.
Üç tane bileşeni var
bu yetkin aklın, birleşik aklın:
Bir tanesi "kalabalık bilgeliği" deniyor.
İlk 1906'da Londra Tarım Fuarı'nda
Sir Francis Galton diye
bir kişi tarafından
-Darwin'in yeğeni oluyor-
onun tarafından yapılıyor.
Rastgele bir araya gelmiş
800 kişinin evvelden tartılmış,
ama onlar tarafından bilinmeyen
bir büyükbaş hayvanın ağırlığını
1 pound farkla, 1397 doğrusu
1396 pound olarak tahmin edebiliyorlar.
Kalabalık bilgeliği o günden bugüne
inanılamaz aşamalar gösterdi.
Bir şeyi bu.
Bugün bunların ürünlerini kullanıyoruz.
Wikipedia diye hepimizin her gün
elimizin altında bulunan dev ansiklopedi,
bu yöntemle oluşuyor.
Siz de isterseniz,
içinizden kim istiyorsa,
şu anda Wikipedia'ya
herhangi madde önerebilir,
onda değişiklik yapabilir,
başkası tarafından üretilmiş olanı
değiştirebilir vesaire falan.
Kalabalık bilgeliği yoluyla
Wikipedia oluşuyor.
Bunun gibi Wikimedia var,
işte Wikileaks var.
Wiki ekonomisi dediğimiz
kalabalık ekonomisi,
yani dayanışmalı ekonomi var.
"Innocentive" dediğimiz,
inovasyon yapma kısmı var
ve TEDx'in kendisi de burada
ve dünyanın çeşitli yerlerinde,
kalabalık bilgeliğe bir örnektir.
Bir bileşen bu yetkin akılda.
İkincisi, "hayvan bilgeliği".
Bugün hayvanlarla ilgili, ben de not
aldım burada, müthiş şeyler söylendi.
Biomimicry'yi zaten kullanıyoruz
yaptığımız tasarımlarda;
mayo yaparken kullanıyoruz
daha hızlı yüzmek için,
uçakların burunlarını yapıyoruz
daha hızlı uçmak için vesaire filan.
Ama bugün sizinle paylaşmak
istediğim önemli bir konu,
bu küme aklı veya sürü aklı denilen
"Swarm Intelligence".
Nasıl ki bilgisayarlarda
chip'leri birleştirerek
daha yetkin, daha geniş hafızalı
bilgisayarlar yapıyorsak
tek tek insanların
akıllarını birleştirerek
onların her birlerinden daha akıllı,
hatta toplamlarından daha akıllı
bir birleşik akıl yaratma teknolojisi.
Teknoloji diyorum, gerçekten teknoloji,
buna ait algoritmalar falan yazılıyor.
Biraz sonra söyleyeceğim,
biz de biraz uğraşıyoruz bu konuyla.
Üçüncüsü de -bu da
en az ikisi kadar önemli-
"Akıl ve sezginin etkileşimi".
Aklı biliyoruz, zaten onun yetkin aklın
bileşenlerinden bir tanesi.
E sezgi ne oluyor; sezgi bugüne kadar
hep tü kaka oldu, üvey evlat gibiydi.
Şimdi sezgi laboratuvar ortamına girdi.
Avustralya'da yapılan deneylerle
bunun var olduğu kanıtlandı.
Dünyada yapılmış bugüne kadar
10 milyonu aşkın patent var
ve bir o kadar keşif var.
Bunların hepsi istisnasız,
"...mi acaba?" sorusuyla başlıyor.
"...mi acaba?" sezgi sorusu,
"...mi acaba?" akıl sorusu değil.
Bilmiyorsunuz, sadece atıyorsunuz.
İşte akıl ve sezginin
etkileşimi de üçüncü kısmı.
Şimdi, tamam yetkin aklı böyle oluşturduk,
bundan çözüm ihtiyacımız var.
Çözümün dayanağı "tohum"
dediğiniz yeni bir konsepttir.
Orada iki an benzerliğinden
yararlanmak istiyorum.
Bir tanesi bedensel işlevlerimiz,
bir tanesi de kültürel işlevlerimiz.
Bedensel işlevlerde,
şurada görünüyor, ama uzaktan
okunması mümkün değil,
omurilikten çıkan sinirlerin,
vücudun hangi bölümlerini
kontrol ettiği gösteriliyor.
Vücudun herhangi bir yerindeki problemler,
orayı kontrol eden sinir düğüm ucuna
uyarılar vererek
-iyileştirici uyarılar vererek-
iyileştirilmeye çalışılıyor.
Tedavi ediliyor, peki.
Bedende böyle çözülüyor problemler.
Kültürel konuda
kültürel işlevlerimiz var.
Nedir?
Çalışmak,
eğlenmek,
öğrenmek,
hatırlamak,
kavga etmek,
dövüş etmek,
tartışmak,
ortak akıl bulmak,
itiraz etmek vesaire gibi
yüzlerce binlerce kültürel işleviniz var.
Bu işlevlerde sorunlar oluyor,
aynen beden gibi bunlarda da
hastalanmalar oluyor.
Bugünkü bütün bu sorun
stokunun yapı taşları,
işte bu hastalanmış
kültürel işlevlerde yatıyor.
Bunların tedavisi için de
bir yöntem bulmamız gerekiyor.
Nasıl ki bedensel sinir uçlarına
onu iyileştirici uyarılar veriyor
ve o şekilde düzeltiyor isek
kültürel işlevlerin arızalı olanlarına da
verilebilecek bir uyarıya ihtiyaç var.
O uyarıya "tohum" adını veriyorum.
Uyardığı alanda iyileşme
sağlayabilecek olan bir davranış,
tohumun tanımı böyle.
Şimdi örnek vereyim bir tane;
özgüven, kültürel işlevlerden bir tanesi
ve çok önemli bir işlev.
Bunun eksikliği
türlü problemler yaratıyor,
bunu söylememe lüzum yok.
Bunun için ben rastgele
iki tane tohum seçtim,
onlara öneriyorum.
Bir tanesi "bilmiyorum"dan yararlanmak,
"bilmiyorum" bizim
kodlarımıza göre ayıptır.
"Bilmiyorum" denmez.
Dolayısıyla "bilmiyorum"dan
utanmamak iyileştirici bir tohumdur,
özgüveni yükseltir.
İkincisi de
kendine söz vermek.
Yani karşısındaki birisine
senet imzalamak falan değil,
kendi kendine taahhütte bulunmak.
Buradaki sihir de şurada,
bu da ilginç bir tarafı,
şimdi hepinizin aklına gelen
bir soru olduğundan eminim.
Peki nasıl olacak, herhangi
bir noktada iyileşme sağladık,
bizim koca bir stokumuz var okyanus gibi.
Bu milyonlarca tohumu kim saçacak,
kim yapacak bunları?
İşte burada tohumların
kendi içinde bir özelliği var,
kanıtlanabilir bir özellik bu.
Buna "genişleme yoluyla
yaygınlaşma" diyoruz, difüzyon etkisi.
Her tohum sadece bir tek
kendi niyetlendiği alanda değil,
özgüven alanında değil mesela,
başka o özgüven eksikliğinin yarattığı
sorun alanlarında da
o ikincil, üçüncül, dördüncül sorunları
hafifleterek veya yok ederek
daha geniş bir alanda iyileşme sağlıyor.
İşte tohumların bu şekilde
bilinçli kullanılması hâlinde
böyle bir imkân doğuyor.
Şimdi "Euraka!" diyebileceğim
başka bir şey çıkıyor.
Baştan söyledim ki milyarlarca insan
ellerini kavuşturmuş bekliyorlar;
ben ne yapabilirim bu stok altında, diye.
Onlara doğrudan doğruya
değişimi yaratma şansı, imkanı
çıkıyor bu tohumlar yoluyla;
çünkü tohumlar öyle ki
bireyler tarafından kullanılabilen
ve kullanıldığı alanda giderek
kendini yaygınlaştıran davranışlar.
Böyle bir imkân çıkıyor.
Birkaç tane tohum örneği süratle geçeyim.
"Korkmama özgürlüğü"
bizim kavram dağarcığımızda yok,
ama bu çok önemli bir kavram.
İkincisi, çocuklarımıza
oyun için fırsat yaratmak.
En büyük eğitim devrimi bu olabilir belki.
Öbürü,
"ben doğru davranacağım" karşılığında,
karşınızdakinin de "ben de
senin beyanına güveneceğim".
Beyana güvenme, bütün
öykündüğümüz ülkelerin modeli bu
ve bir diğeri de her gün çocukların
veya erişkinlerin -bizlerin-
bir yeni kavram,
bir yeni sözcük öğrenmeleri.
Bunların beklentileri yanlarında
yazdı, ama geçiyorum.
Şimdi bir sosyal deney.
Bütün bu söylediklerim
acaba yapılabilir mi?
Evet, Birleşik Akıl Ağı adı
altında bir projede
2017 yılının başından itibaren
yaklaşık 110 kişi oldu şu anda,
Birleşik Akıl Ağı adı altında
bir sosyal deney yapıyorlar.
Şimdi burada, A tipi
platform bu Birleşik Akıl Ağı,
iki tane de temel amacı var:
Bir tanesi, bir Wiki altyapısı,
yani katılımlı katkı yaratma
altyapısı sunarak
yetkin akıl yoluyla
hem yetkin akıl yaratmak,
hem de o yolla, tohumlar yoluyla
çözüm üretilmesini kolaylaştırmak,
böyle bir platform.
Kim isterse bedava olarak
bunu kullansın istiyoruz.
Sunduğu altyapıyı,
bir taraftan da geliştirebilmesi için
deneyler yapması lazım.
Neyin üstüne? Türkiye sorunları üstüne.
Bugüne kadar 20 sorun alanı
ortak akılla belirlendi:
İşte dinin istismarı,
eğitim, kadın, beka,
toplumsal manifesto vesaire gibi şeyler
ve tohum sayısı olarak da 100'ü aştı,
böyle tohum üretti arkadaşlarımız.
Ama en önemli aracı,
coğrafyada ve zamandan bağımsız
ortak akıl üretebilmek,
birleşik akıl üretebilmek.
Şurada bir şeyde göreceksiniz,
E-Beyin Fırtınası dedik buna.
Şurada dünyanın çeşitli yerlerine dağılmış
birtakım insanlar görüyorsunuz.
Bu gerçek bir şeyi gösteriyor.
Kimi Türkiye'nin çeşitli illerinde,
kimi Colorado'da,
kimi Kuzey Carolina'da,
kimi Hollanda'da;
herkes başka bir tarafta.
Ama bunlar aynı anda
bir soruya cevap arıyorlar
ve bunu bulut üzerinde
bir belgede kullanıyorlar,
bunu hepiniz zaten kullanıyorsunuz,
fotoğraflarınızı falan koyuyorsunuz.
Ama bunu, sorun çözme amacıyla
böyle online olarak kullanma konusunda
böyle de bir şeyi bütün
herkese burada sunuyorum.
İki akıl -eğer
birbirlerinden farklı iseler-
bir akıldan daha iyidir.
Farklı değilse bir işe yaramaz.
İki türün aklı,
biri insan türü, öbürü başka bir türün
-hayvanlar, bitkiler, doğa neyse-
iki türün aklı -eğer onların akıl dilini
öğrenmeye gayret ederseniz-
birisinden çok daha iyidir.
Sezgisiz akıl zaten bilinenden
başka bir şey değildir,
dolayısıyla kördür.
Sezgiyle birleştirilmiş akıl ise
mükemmel bir yol göstericidir.
Yeterli sayıda tekrarlanan
her etki çevresini değiştirir.
Tohumlar,
çaresiz bireylerin her birinin
değişime katkıda bulunması için
özel olarak kendilerine özgü
birer değişim yaratma lisansı yaratıyor.
Bu, bu salondakiler için de doğru.
Herkes için çok doğru.
Hepinize teşekkür ederim.
(Alkışlar)